[Musique]
on va la manifestation du 1er mai et on
va rejoindre
la brave Jérôme du Rhin sénateur
socialiste se rendent à la manif du 1er
mai à Paris il a rendez-vous avec une
unité de la brave la brigade de
répression de l'action violente
mais que va faire un élu de gauche avec
les forces de l'ordre un jour de fête du
travail le rapport police population il
est parfois compliqué c'est dans le
domaine du maintien de l'ordre que celle
qui est compliqué qu'on a un vrai sujet
politique démocratique
les lois anti-casseurs les gilets jaunes
l'usage dlbd les blessures
infligées aux manifestants ça mérite des
documentés des associations de fond et
puis nous il faut dans le cadre de notre
travail parlementaire qu'on sache
réellement ce qui se passe donc moi je
suis manifestant la plupart du temps du
côté des manifestants et aujourd'hui je
suis de l'autre côté pour voir comment
ça se passe
c'est vous qui êtes au
[Musique]
ok je vois j'arrive
si le sénateur veut aller voir sur le
terrain c'est parce que le maintien de
l'ordre à la française interroge ça vous
le mettez ici très bien la France
affiche le plus lourd bilan humain en
Europe en la matière trois morts depuis
2014 des dizaines de mutilés une
contestation de la réforme des retraites
émaillée d'accusation de violences
policières et de manifestants dans le
coma après les affrontements à Sainte
solide j'ai eu la chance c'est juste un
doigt
et il y a des gens qui ont bien pire au
Sénat la gauche dénonce une dérivée
précise du maintien de l'ordre la droite
défend policier et gendarmes et blâme la
radicalisation des manifestants on a eu
plus de 1500 policiers qui ont été
blessés vous avez des individus qui
viennent avec des boules de pétanque de
l'acide qui projette des cocktails
incendiaires face à la montée de la
violence faut-il réinterroger notre
doctrine où en est-on du maintien de
l'ordre en France
[Musique]
les violences en manifs Anna Marguerita
les traque avec son appareil photo
c'est suite au mouvement des gilets
jaunes en 2018 et 2019 que j'ai commencé
à sortir avec mon petit appareil photo
[Musique]
c'était pas professionnel à ce moment là
mais je me suis rendu compte de
l'importance que pouvait avoir dans
certains moments la captation d'image
[Musique]
notamment dans les moments de violence
en fait pour prouver les violences
l'importance de l'image devenu photos
journaliste Anna travaille aujourd'hui
pour une agence de presse qui vend ces
images à des journaux français et
étrangers le 15 avril elle était à
Rennes pour couvrir une manifestation
contre la réforme des retraites le 15
avril donc à Rennes s'est tenu une
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites
le cortège initial était très calme
plutôt syndical
ça se passait très bien et très vite le
cortège est devenu un peu plus informel
on va dire et un peu plus offensif
les personnes
les plus déterminées on va dire on
commençait à prendre vraiment de la
place dans les rues et le cortège a
commencé à prendre des directions qui ne
faisaient pas partie du du parcours qui
avait été déclaré et autorisé
j'ai été alerté par le cri d'une femme
et en me retournant j'ai vu qu'elle
était plaquée au sol par deux policiers
et en faisant une photographie de de
cette interpellation j'ai vu en
arrière-plan qu'un homme se faisait
également interpeller alors qu'il
réagissait à cette première
interpellation
la scène que décrit Anna a été filmée
depuis un balcon
ils sont donc 5 policiers autour de
l'homme qui crie de douleur parce qu'il
a on lui tire la cheville on lui tire la
jambe on dirait qu'on est en train de
l'écarteler alors qu'il est parfaitement
immobilisé je vois pas quel qu'est-ce
qui pourrait faire
pour se rebeller à ce moment là quoi
c'est alors qu'Ana va filmer quelques
secondes qui vont faire le tour des
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
pas le droit mais toi tu nous sur son
dos vous allez la succès comme ça c'est
interdit ma place
on était un malade t'es un malade tu
sors de la vie dépoter maintenant
un policier place un genou sur le dos de
l'homme et son second genou sur le coup
de l'homme si le placage ventral est une
technique légale bien que décrié écraser
le coût d'une personne pour
l'immobiliser est officiellement
interdit j'ai un peu laissé tomber ma
carte de journaliste et c'était assez
informel en fait ma façon de m'adresser
à eux mais parce que j'ai simplement eu
peur réellement pour pour la vie de
l'homme quoi c'est des gestes qu'on a
déjà vu et qu'on associe parfois à la
mort donc ça j'ai été profondément
choquée d'assister à ça et dès que le
genou s'est placé sur le coup de l'homme
je suis intervenu verbalement j'ai pas
pu m'en empêcher
parce que il me semblait qu'à ce moment
là la vie de cet homme était en danger
mettez un malade braque avec un
lance-grenade multicou
juste au niveau de mon visage vraiment
presque collé à mon visage en me hurlant
tu dégages tu dégages pour m'éloigner en
fait de la scène c'est un geste qui est
proscrit par tous les schémas du
maintien de l'ordre disproportionné qui
n'avait pas raison d'être à ce moment-là
sur d'autres images on voit le même
fonctionnaire mettre en jeu des
manifestants avec la même arbre
normalement un tiers avec un
lance-grenade multicou se fait à 45
degrés en cloche les tirs tendus ne sont
pas autorisés avec cette arme là donc là
une grenade lancée dans la tête ça veut
dire avoir la tête qui se fait exploser
quoi
sur la base des images tournées par Anna
le procureur de la République de Rennes
a ouvert une enquête confiée à l'IGPN
le porte-parole de la police nationale
ne veut pas commenter l'interpellation
mais reconnaît tout de même un dérapage
de la part du fonctionnaire au
lance-grenades
qui peut apparaître comme un gestina
adapté comme un geste qui peut aussi
apparaître comme menaçant vis-à-vis de
cette journaliste qui a décliné sa
qualité ce ne sont pas des choses qui
sont préconisées évidemment il n'y a pas
eu d'usage de l'arme mais ce côté
menaçant n'était pas adapté
les policiers respectent-ils vraiment
l'usage strictement proportionné de la
force
tandis que les images de violence se
multiplient la pression monte sur le
Gouvernement et la commission des Lois
du Sénat odysse le ministre de
l'Intérieur
du Stade de France au rue de Paris ou de
Bordeaux forcer de constater que nous
constatons trop de dysfonctionnement et
tout n'est pas toujours de la faute des
autres les manifestants les supporters
des clubs de football étrangers les
membres de l'ultra-droite ou l'ultra
gauche il y aura tout le temps des gens
qui voudront causer des désordres le
maintien de l'ordre c'est fait pour ça
Gérald Darmanin défend ses troupes et
lance un défi au sénateur passer une
journée avec la brave pour voir ce qui
toute la journée
ils ont comme violence en face de
n'hésitez pas moi j'encourage demain je
vous donne rendez-vous si vous le
souhaitez évidemment c'est total liberté
vous venez à 8 heures du matin 7h du
matin on prend toute la journée parmi
les manifestations n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à venir malheureusement je
constate que c'est plus facile de le
faire de loin que de le faire de près
auprès d'eux
[Musique]
le sénateur Jérôme Durin relève le gant
le voici parti en observation avec des
policiers lors de la manifestation du
1er mai à Paris
qui vont être à distance des cortèges
pour
intervenir en cas de
l'intervention de Black Bloc de
personnes qui s'en prendraient ou bien
ou aux personnes là il y a quand même 42
42 forces au total ma doctrine à moi
avec mes attendus politiques et mes
convictions c'est
une stratégie de des escalade c'est
un ordre public républicain ferme mais
respectueux des libertés individuelles
voilà donc une fois que j'ai dit ça
c'est ce que je veux confronter à la
réalité du terrain comment comment ces
convictions là et comment c'est principe
politique s'accommodent de la réalité du
terrain c'est tout l'intérêt de cette
immersion
142 300 je confirme à tout le monde est
parti sur Saint-Maur la préfecture
anticipe 2000 Black Blocs ce jour-là le
dispositif policier est conséquent on a
des civils dans les dans le cortège qui
passe des physios ils sont en noir et
ils se grippe comme des Black Blocs du
coup et eux on a un gros WhatsApp en
commun où on peut regarder enfin on
arrive à voir l'ambiance
[Musique]
l'unité de Jérôme du Rhin se déplace en
parallèle de la manifestation prête à
charger en cas de débordement à l'avant
du cortège
[Applaudissements]
grosse attaque et donc visiblement ils
sont prêts à des commerces et ça a
tapait fort
pour les yeux
ils essayent d'organiser la fluidité du
parcours pour pas que ça bloque pas que
ça fasse de points de fixation et donc
ils interviennent à échéance régulière
parfois qu'on tourne le dispositif le
défilé pour que tout ça continue et de
progresser
de
Black Bloc ils appellent ça nébuleuse
qui qui sont pris à des agences
bancaires des commerces effectivement
ça c'est ce qui c'est ce qui a été
envoyé
aux forces de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la question centrale c'est celle de la
violence il y a un usage de la force moi
j'ai vu l'usage de la force
est-ce que cette
usage là est légitime ou pas je suis pas
qualifié sur le moment pour dire c'est
les bonnes personnes quand unité charge
de personnes de deux ou trois
fonctionnaires il sort pour aller
interpeller quelqu'un à la fin moi je
pense qu'ils sont les bonnes
informations les ont-ils je suis pas
qualifié pour le dire en revanche oui
c'est violent effectivement alors moi
j'ai pas vu une science policière j'ai
pas vu des types qui
fonctionnent la police qui tapait
n'importe comment à tort et à travers
mais effectivement c'est l'usage de la
force je suis pas dupe de la façon dont
ça s'est organisé des précautions qui
ont pu être faites mais j'en reviens
quand même assez marqué par le niveau de
violence que que les forces de l'ordre
Suisse
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre est un métier
difficile alors des Black Blocs les
manifs ont changé de visage
en marge des cortèges bien ordonnés
encadrés par les syndicats sont apparus
des mouvements plus éruptifs face à ce
phénomène le maintien de l'ordre
n'a-t-il fait que réagir ou bien a-t-il
une part de responsabilité dans la
spirale de la violence
si on compare un maintien de l'ordre du
point de vue des dégâts humains qui
n'engendrent en France par rapport aux
autres pays européens et la France est
caracolent en tête des
dommages corporels au cours de
d'opérations
et des dommages graves
auteur de nombreuses enquêtes de terrain
le chercheur Fabien Jobard scrutin la
sablement le travail des forces de
l'ordre
dans les années 90 2000 ce qui se
multiplie en France sont ce qu'on
appelle les violences urbaines
[Musique]
il y a eu une contamination du maintien
de danse c'est-à-dire de la gestion des
manifestations par les violences
urbaines la réponse aux violences
urbaines telle qu'elle a été conçue
telle qu'elle a été équipée dotée durant
les années 90 et surtout durant les
années 2000 une décennie pendant
laquelle le sociologue a observé ce
qu'il appelle la brutalisation du
maintien de l'ordre c'est l'impact à qui
est recherché en violant urbaine c'est
l'impact en maintien de l'ordre on est
sur une disposition tout à fait
différente manifestation ce qui est un
rechercher c'est le contrôle des foules
on va essayer de faire en sorte que la
foule
aille d'un point un autre sans commettre
de dégâts et quand on a vu notamment
avec la loi travail 2016 les mouvements
sociaux tels qu'on les connaît
habituellement revenir sur le devant de
la scène le maintien de l'ordre il avait
été pendant 20 ans contaminé par les
violences urbaines les équipements
n'étaient pas les mêmes
les doctrines n'étaient plus vraiment
les mêmes
et puis la culture aussi des policiers
avait changé c'est ça qui fait
la la dureté la prêter
la violence de la réponse au
mouvement sociaux
on devient policier parce que on a
l'envie de vouloir participer à la vie
de la société et de pouvoir apporter sa
pierre à l'édifice
c'est un sens très fort en fait on
devient trop policier par hasard c'est
une vocation cette évolution du maintien
de l'ordre Olivier cap l'a vécu de
l'intérieur il a 25 ans de boutique au
sein de la CRS 45 basé à Genas près de
Lyon 45 c'est l'un des plus gros sites
CRS de France si ce n'est le plus grand
une CRS que j'ai intégré en 98
le premier décembre de 2018 a été la
journée de maintien de l'ordre la plus
la plus marquante pour moi
parce qu'il y en a une intensité de
violence que j'avais jamais connu
le premier dans cette grenade c'est 8h
du matin et fin de journée c'est zéro
heure quoi enfin minuit
donc ça vous laisse un petit peu comment
dire
imaginez la journée qu'on a passé le
maintien de l'ordre c'est un métier
c'est un métier qui est dédié
normalement aux forces mobiles
compagnies républicaine de sécurité
gendarmes mobiles compagnie
d'intervention
ces forces dédiées au maintien de
l'ordre ont vu leurs effectifs baissés
sous le quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy
une compagnie traditionnelle quand je
suis rentré dans la police nationale et
notamment en CRS c'était quasiment 170
fonctionnaires on est descendu avec
aujourd'hui un effectif de 133 sur une
compagnie donc lorsque il vous arrive
des événements type gilet jaune type loi
el khomri
réforme des retraites etc vous avez où
vous avez besoin d'énormément
d'effectifs pour pouvoir maintenir
l'ordre
et bien vous vous rendez compte que
finalement vous avez passé le mandat
donc est-ce que vous faites
vous allez chercher des collègues qui ne
sont pas aguerris en maintien de l'ordre
qui sont beaucoup plus spécialisés je
pense au bac sur le flagrant délit mais
qui font très peu de maintien de l'ordre
c'est pas leur coeur de métier leur cœur
de métier c'est le flagrant délit et ce
qu'on appelle le saute dessus ça peut
amener aussi à l'utilisation du LBD et
pas forcément abonnés sur ce recours à
toujours plus au niveau de la
graturation de la force et intimement
lié au manque d'effectif sur les rangs
[Musique]
au manif de plus en plus violentes le
maintien de l'ordre a opposé une
doctrine frontale
parfois les conséquences sont
dramatiques
j'ai fait ça j'ai senti un coup là j'ai
fait ça je voulais me retourner pour
voir si je voyais mes collègues et puis
il va en faisant ce geste là ça va voilà
Doris à 50 ans elle vit à Rouen et
travaille auprès d'enfants handicapés
avec ses camarades de la CGT elle a
participé à toutes les manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites jusqu'à
celle du 23 mars
et donc on suivait notre notre parcours
je pensais être loin de des CRS et à un
moment j'ai senti quelque chose dans mon
épaule du coup je me suis donc ça m'a
fait faire ça je me suis retournée pour
voir où étaient les jeunes qui me
suivaient et les les collègues et au
moment où j'ai fait ça j'ai fait ça et
pouf ça m'a explosé donc j'ai entendu
une détonation mes oreilles ont sifflé
aussitôt donc ça fait je voyais tout au
ralenti en fait et j'ai senti une
douleur une douleur à ma main et une
brûlure enfin j'avais l'impression que
je
pas tout mon corps brûlé mais que
j'avais une partie de mon corps qui
brûlait en fait et j'ai
regardé ma main et je l'ai vu que
j'avais plus de fois qu'elle avait
explosé quoi donc je l'ai récupéré comme
ça j'ai crié au secours j'ai plus de
doigts
[Musique]
a été touché par un tir de Grenade elle
va passer 12 jours à l'hôpital ils ont
fait en sorte que j'ai au moins une
pince pour parce que sinon j'avais plus
de doigts du tout donc ils ont récupéré
un morceau qui pendait pour le remettre
par dessus parce qu'en fait ma
j'ai plus de deuxième phalange j'ai pu
d'articulation là moi jusqu'à présent
les CRS enfin ou même les policiers
c'était pas je les voyais pas du tout
comme ça c'était leur boulot et puis bah
c'était plus de la protection
et bah là c'est plutôt de la protection
en fait
[Musique]
singularité qu'on ne retrouve vraiment
nulle part ailleurs
en Europe du concernant en matière de
l'ordre en France c'est l'équipement des
policiers deux armes en particulier qui
sont les grenades et en particulier les
grenades
explosives qu'elle dégage du gaz ou
qu'elle dégage des palais ou qu'elle
soit simplement explosives
assourdissante et les lanceurs de balle
de défense c'est l'explosion même des
grenades qui
occasionnent la plupart des blessures
dont on entend parler
Doris attend réparation de la justice
son avocate a lancé un appel à témoin
pour recueillir des éléments qu'elle a
transmis au procureur
d'accord on pense que c'est ça
maintenant c'est les analyses des
experts qui vont permettre d'en dire
plus l'IGPN va aussi examiner les vidéos
je pense va essayer d'entendre aussi des
personnes du côté de la police j'espère
pour comprendre qui a pu tirer et dans
quelles circonstances on la récupère les
dizaines de témoignages qui ont été
fournis à la justice ces témoignages-là
qui sont sur le vif et qui permettent
vraiment de retracer précisément ce
qu'ils ont entendu vu et ben il n'aurait
pas existé dans le dossier si on n'avait
pas fait ce travail là c'est toute la
difficulté de ce type de dossier c'est
identifier qui est le policier ou le
gendarme en tout cas le membre des
forces de l'ordre qui va avoir tiré
l'arme qui a servi à blesser la victime
dans un certain nombre de dossiers on
vient conclure en disant on ne sait pas
de qui il s'agit
comme Doris de nombreuses victimes
redoutent l'impunité des fonctionnaires
en cas de bavure
en théorie les policiers et gendarmes
doivent pourtant être identifiables par
leur matricule sur le terrain
sept chiffres appelés Rio pour
référentiel des identités de
l'organisation de nombreux enquêtes de
l'IGPN sont classées sans suite faute
d'avoir pu identifier les auteurs des
manquements alors que comptez-vous faire
monsieur le ministre pour augmenter le
port du Rio au-delà des rappels de cette
obligation il y en a eu 18 depuis 2013
vous avez raison il y a des policiers
des jambes qui portent pas leur
immatriculation bah c'est effectivement
au contraire aux règles vous avez
rappelé vous-même d'ailleurs qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de rappels aux règles
faut-il aller plus loin écoutez on va y
réfléchir
[Musique]
les bénévoles de la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme mènent un travail d'observation
au long cours du maintien de l'ordre
comme à Bordeaux le 1er mai
nous démarrons nous sommes 6 il y aura
deux équipes de trois personnes le sens
de la présence des observateurs c'est
effectivement de veiller
aux conditions de mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre par les
forces de l'ordre on est en comportement
de Total neutralité par rapport aux
manifestants notre endroit d'observation
plus récent
[Musique]
nous sommes en train simplement de
vérifier ou de noter la manière dont les
forces de l'ordre sont positionnés en
gros les effectifs et les forces
déployées il y a des jets de gaz à
clairon qui c'est poursuivent
actuellement
sur la rue Sainte-Catherine
les observateurs notent tout et tracent
la présence du matricule sur les
fonctionnaires
pour l'instant il y a rien à signaler il
y a simplement quelques observations sur
le nom port de Rio ou le port de cagoule
ne s'agissant pas de personnels de
police antiterroriste théorie comment
ils ont pas le droit de porter la
cagoule à ce stade là
pourtant inscrit dans le code de la
sécurité intérieure le port du Rio est
aléatoire parmi les fonctionnaires
déployés à Bordeaux ce jour-là la manif
bon beaucoup de monde globalement une
bonne tenue dans les constats qu'on a pu
faire directement aucune observation de
comportement je dirais complètement
disproportionné les éco-conaces et
qu'effectivement c'était une des plus
grosses manifestations si ce n'est la
plus grosse depuis le début des manifs
des retraites à Bordeaux et pourtant
c'est globalement bien passé
voilà quelques années que les policiers
les gendarmes ont l'obligation d'avoir
leur numéro d'identification il y a eu
sans doute une réalité dans le fait que
certains policiers ne le portaient pas
les rappels et les sanctions elles
peuvent intervenir ou elles
interviennent même parce que c'est
important de faire respecter nourrir le
sentiment auprès des manifestants ou des
Français tout simplement que les forces
de l'ordre chercheraient à organiser
leur impunité c'est totalement faux ce
serait le même insupportable pour les
policiers que nous sommes
comment faire baisser la tension autour
du maintien de l'ordre le port
systématique du Rio serait peut-être une
première étape mais l'essentiel de la
solution est sans doute politique cette
situation je dirais social qui devrait
être résolu par des décisions politiques
nous emmène souvent la confrontation ce
manque d'effectif
à retentissement sur
la société tout entière puisqu'en fait
qu'est-ce qui trinque en fait c'est
l'effort de l'ordre mais aussi le
citoyen qui lui vient manifester on sent
que les forces de l'ordre elles payent
pour d'autres ça vaut politiquement pour
un climat social délétère et du coup ils
sont le réceptacle
bouc émissaire d'une certaine manière et
visibilise le pouvoir c'est la police du
pouvoir et là ils incarnaient Macron
quand on voulait s'en prendre à Macron
retraite ou 49-3 bah c'est les policiers
en fin de cortège qui incarnent tout ça
ils payent
aussi pour leur chef et pour la doctrine
de maintien de l'ordre qui est mise en
œuvre
[Musique]